oh [__] it's that time [__] it's
the best time of your [__] day
that's what you to commit ly snow this
oh this is oh [__] oh [__] is right
[__] what is this this is
communist weed right here oh oh some
purple oh yeah this is the real [__]
deal
[Music]
[__] grinders anything else these
[__] people do everything cost you
money at the end what the [__] do you
need it for they just tell you you need
it and you think it is then you might
want I've been doing this for thirty
[__] years yeah you're saying [__]
these [__]
[Music]
don't man that make [__]
BAM it's your backdoor [__] man uncle
Joey here come and direct to you with
this [__] gorilla glue tell them what
it smells like Lee oh my god and it's
[__] beautiful
preacher chin this [__] here
this stuff no no this is purple blue
gray look at this [__]
these bud is the inside of this coconut
oh my god and me and Lee about the burn
this [__] down we got stars
we got mushrooms and we got number the
heart [__] you understand me
something that's been forgotten in this
[__] country but you got to read
about everything I got to read about
what that animal does to me go [__]
yourself you got to read what be
Scholastic you know say gonna look at
that huh we're gonna get that type
action with your friends at star but we
put a little pipe get the [__] out of
here
there's the uncle Joey our [__] with
my main [__] you do the main
[__] Jew there's like twenty two good
ones left and I got one of them right
here
one do it slow do it slow all right
take good time
[Music]
because it's raining jacks this what
Michael thumps was wagging the dog you
know didn't help look at him now look at
him now is [__]
that's it [__] we're here oh
hey look we're that's a boy
Corp that [__] out what the kettlebells
don't get out the [__] bomb will
you're saying haha hey if you're not
gonna go have a good time go [__]
yourself yes what the [__] what are you
mad about what I used to walk around mad
and angry about [__] that happened 20
years ago I got my little brother leave
we got the stars of debt look at leas
back he said that was a fluke [__]
we're going deep on this [__] of
debt tonight you know why this is
Wednesday night and we lead by example
okay you want the masses to come out and
do bong hits you got to open up with a
[__] bong hit you follow me it's just
that simple yeah me I don't give a [__]
no more I got nothing else going on
tonight
don't tomorrow we go to the deck here
you understand me wants this one
let's do doctor police's breathing
exercises you ready you know I'm saying
if a left hook won't get you that will
[__] that's it it's that simple
what's with the drama what's with the
tears
please ready for another one these in
training
Oh Michel folks started some way you
understand me
this never ends you always a training
black belt still flocking train every
day you understand even the [__]
black belts train every day right or
wrong am i bullshitting it now if you're
gonna be a black belt
do you bother to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier sorry button things happen
you know I'm saying I don't want to give
the win I don't want to give Lee any
[__] lint in this head this is a
[__] tremendous hit for you people
out of respect
look what we found here oh [__]
the stars of la muerte I hope you guys
are having a great Wednesday uncle Joey
here with my main brother Lisa at
showing you how the party gets [__]
started here
you know you think we come here and talk
you know I opened here to [__] you an
uber goalie you [__] Savage look
nice and slow slow slow monitor that
smoke that's a boy to your stomach
doctor please pick that up clean that up
you see what I'm saying
[__] endurance you got a built it
[__]
this ain't no mental hopscotch yeah I'm
saying the same Michael Jackson and this
ain't thrill of [__] let me get that
lighter dawg we gotta get we gotta set
this [__] off right what'd you
say you ready for some stars so am I
[Music]
most of you [__] amateurs gotta get a
vapor pen look at me look at me and
[__] get the [__] out of it
if you can't blow that on the natch hold
on and that should take a chance
Columbus there was this a purple one 200
milligram there goes one mm-hmm that
goes to there goes three and [__] for
just like that you know why cuz it's
Wednesday and you know you wanna party
with the big boys that's it everybody
wants to get that twos and everybody's
in the Mafia
hey y'all ain't hungry to start off with
and what the [__] I think we're doing it
today thousand apiece why not yeah what
have you done with your [__] life
today you want me tell me things I did
today
a lot on floor I was sleep i watch the
cooler last night I got all excited
hey little buddy that's for you thank
you that's one we'll give you three more
four more
we're gonna be fine young Sam who said
mushrooms tonight it might be one of
those nights you understand me people
I'm gonna [__] up mood today
had a good day with the family I had a
good day with my brother Lee I had a
good day with my girl Becky was out
today I saw at the coffee shop not
Starbucks the other one we hang with
undisclosed locations and that's it I
don't know what else to tell you
what he would think we should we do
another bong I was thinking the same
[__] thing you know me
there's always nella from the room
there's a fungus three people somebody's
gotta do something to get this damage
your lungs on fire because it's good
it's a good [__] sign when your lungs
on fire after you do bunkie you let your
lungs no listen I don't [__] around
don't get up do it Scott stretch and do
whatever the [__] you need to do long
and cuz we're coming in with the heavy
duty look at this leave this one here
but you're this that's a [__]
beautiful you were gonna Boston Market
and the thing is spinning on a
rotisserie leave this blood on the
rotisserie okay you bad [__]
you you thought you guys tuned into a
good [__] night yeah I'm saying it's
a good [__] you're gay I could ask
worse do something he gets that down the
corner there something like that just to
bring me back to my roots you know I'm
saying I wish you could smoke this
reefer remember one Denzel tells the guy
with the bomb up his ass I wish you had
more time right now I wish you could
smell this [__] Aretha I swear to God
I went to the store after jujitsu before
my meeting and I left it in the car
fermenting all afternoon you understand
me it was like 94 degree heat in the Sun
I parked it in the Sun [__] the trees
Hidan I couldn't even touch this thing
we're gonna have Beauty over there look
at that you saw me saying listen
I don't know what to tell you the whole
one kind of day is that I don't even
don't want to [__] that I only want
to tell you I'm happy you're here that's
all that [__] matters I'm happy
you're here you could be out there
[__] you know at a Turkish airport or
something god forbid people flying to
Turkey tonight let me tell you some I
cancel that ticket on New York minute
are you kidding me I get 10 10 round
trips to [__] in Santa Fe and cuál the
night I wouldn't fly into [__] Turk
you know those airports right now if you
take a look come on overseas this summer
shoot yourself in the head right now
it's Russian roulette you're like
Christopher Walken is a deer hunter
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you're gonna see the devil you know
you gotta piss here I'm sorry we got
[__] mental leave the door oh but if
you want we gotta have it out in here
before people start complaining that it
smells like a [__] opium den in here
which would with I'm saying we're just
doing a podcast well I got American band
we just want a [__] party do a
podcast like we'll do an alcohol or
shooting how would you smoke a little
reefer read some metal piece and we're
listening to the doors listen to this
[__]
- me
this is the [__] setting ran with
[__] Lauren she's going into [__]
Marlon Brando this tremendous
[Music]
you know there's always a [__] man
you know we were smoking hash out these
[__] remember these buttons Hillary
Clinton but now I use them as a polka
for the [__] see it's like crazy cool
million one [__] users of my work
there's always something you can [__]
use a fork
should we give Lee another bum head and
put them over on my bong if I could have
bronchitis for a month watch wait do you
see this [__] everything [__]
meshugganah juice [__] everything
this book kid least I got some [__]
soldier my eyes guys it's tough to run
with math label on a daily you [__]
out of your mind
this kids over at the house with taking
rides of them you know and every time I
see
it's either a DOS or a [__] bong in
or something Lisa at your up brother I
got more for you right there's a nice
little baby one is [__] guys here we go
[Music]
I told you listen up the [__]
dedication okay if you're not gonna
dedicate yourself and [__] commit to
whatever the [__] you want to be a baker
you wanna make bagels you want to be a
[__] fireman whatever the [__] you
want to do you gotta commit me I want to
smoke reefer with three hands [__]
listen to the doors why are you worrying
about Isis and who's gonna be President
I don't give a [__] cause at the end of
the day you still gotta pay for your
groceries at the supermarket even if a
blanket makes a comeback it's don't
worry gross [__] the [__] coupons
right or wrong
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
[__] and we'll be back in about
10 minutes YouTube [__]
I love you stay black Thank You
forgeting hi we uncle Joey it's always
great you don't get molested you just
get high and that's it you go on home
nobody's gonna get fingered nothing